[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette année d'interdire
le rapport sauvé steam à 216 me le
nombre de mineurs qui auraient été
victimes de violences sexuelles de la
part d'un prêtre ou d'une religieuse
entre 1950 et 2020 le chiffre monte à
330 milles si l'on étend à celles et
ceux qui auraient été agressées
sexuellement par une personne en lien
avec l'église alors pourquoi un tel
phénomène caractère systémique dans
l'église catholique est pas dans
l'église protestante ou dans le judaïsme
ou dans l'islam à cause du célibat
imposé aux prêtres et religieuses à
cause du secret de la confession
parce que la hiérarchie c'est à dire
l'épiscope pas à laisser faire ou parce
que la parole se libère plus facilement
chez les catholiques que dans les autres
religions monothéistes pour en débattre
nous avons invité walter hallebardiers
vous êtes psychiatre vous êtes le
responsable du cri yav ile de france le
centre ressources pour les intervenants
auprès des auteurs de violences
sexuelles vous soigner des pédophiles et
des pédocriminels dont des prêtres alors
d'après vous pourquoi l'église
catholique pourquoi c'est dans l'église
catholique que le scandale advient alors
déjà c'est par là que vient un scandale
et peut-être que les mois prochains les
deux années prochaines on verra que
c'est pas que la caisse au scandale les
violences sexuelles dans l'église ça
représente 4% des violences sexuelles
sur les enfants en france 1 4 à 6% selon
comprennent les chiffres celles commises
par les prêtres ou plus largement et
puis peut-être parce que ben l'église à
cattolica à fait
cette démarche d'inventaire et de
comptage finalement que d'autres
institutions n'ont pas fait anne soupa
vous êtes théologienne journaliste co
fondatrice du comité de la jupe qui
promeut le féminisme au sein de l'église
catholique et du mouvement de la
conférence catholique des bêtises et
francophones en 2020 vous aviez déposer
votre candidature en tant que laïque
pour le poste d'archevêque de lyon après
la démission de philippe barbarin votre
dernier livre pour l'amour de dieu est
paru en janvier chez albin michel voulzy
plaidé pour la reconnaissance des laïcs
par l'église et de l'épiscopat féminin
alors pour vous pourquoi est-ce que ça
ça se passe dans l'église catholique
aujourd'hui
bonsoir alors main ma réponse est que
l'église catholique est construite sur
des prêtres qui sont entourés du norad
sacralité sans doute excessive et la
sacralité dont ils sont entourés et bien
fait que la personne qui est en
elle occulte heures et plus vulnérable
donc plus susceptible de céder devant
des abus ça c'est la première raison la
deuxième c'est la domination masculine
nathalie bajos de la lie de la case a
dit que plus la domination masculine est
forte plus les violences sexuelles sont
forts
dans ce non partagé qui sait que la
dissimulation est plus facile que plein
air vous êtes théologienne à 25 ans vous
est pris le voile chez les soeurs de
l'assomption et commencer une formation
en théologie mais vous avez quitté la
vie religieuse au bout de sept ans vous
avez rejoint l'institution thérésienne
un groupe international laïque accueille
à la fois des femmes ayant fait le voeu
de célibat et des couples aujourd'hui
vous publiez choisir le célibat avec un
point d'interrogation aux éditions du
cerf un livre d'autant plus intéressant
que le célibat des prêtres est soupçonné
de participer aux scandales qui frappent
aujourd'hui l'église alors pour vous
même question pourquoi l'église
catholique pourquoi c'est là que ça se
passe
parce que je crois qu'elle a un rapport
compliqué complexe depuis longtemps et
encore aujourd'hui à la sexualité elle a
une théologie qui est plus répressive
que réflexive et qui est d'un autre âge
c'est à dire que par exemple elle
n'accepte une sexualité vécue que dans
le couple marié une seule fois
elle est contre la alors que la plupart
des gens en france aujourd'hui se
marient de moins en moins et que tous
cohabitent avant de se marier chose
qu'elle n'accepte pas pareil pour la
pour la la contraception est autre chose
elle a un rapport à la sexualité qui est
vraiment problématique depuis longtemps
et aujourd'hui encore le sujet vous êtes
journaliste au figaro je vais reçus dans
cette émission pour votre livre
l'extinction de l'homme le projet fou
des antispécistes chez tallandier mais
vous avez beaucoup réagi depuis la
publication du rapport sauvé que ce soit
sur twitter ou sur ses news alors pour
vous pourquoi est ce que c'est c'est
dans l'église catholique que ça se
produit
alors oui je crois que effectivement
comme l'a rappelé votre invité en
plateau le mérite de l'église catholique
et de ne pas avoir eu peur quelles que
soient les coûts qu'elle allait recevoir
par la suite de ne pas avoir eu peur de
la vérité et contrairement à d'autres
institutions et qui peuvent parfois
laisser les fesses enterré de même elle
est allée chercher alors il a fallu pour
ça beaucoup de temps probablement que
cette décision de sa part en france en
tout cas est arrivé trop tard beaucoup
trop tard mais elle est allée chercher
elle-même la vérité et en confiant à
monsieur sauver c'est que le choix de
prese de cette commission elle l'état
les traquer presque une à une
les les abuseurs en son propre sein pour
essayer d'offrir un recensement
exhaustif des victimes et en tant que
catholique évidemment là la vérité ainsi
mises à nu est extrêmement douloureuse
elle vient ébranler notre rapport à
toute l'institution à sa hiérarchie mais
finalement à travers elle à chaque
prêtre aujourd'hui un catholique qui a
pris connaissance de ce rapport se
demande presque systématiquement si tel
ou tel prêtre ami de la famille où
parents peut être de ceux là aussi et en
même temps ce travail fait pour la
vérité je crois que l'église catholique
aujourd'hui est la seule institution à
l'avoir accompli jusqu au bout et en
cela et bien peut-être que dans sa
déchéance peut-être que dans son
déshonneur elle retrouve justement une
forme de dignité au moment même où on
croyait l'institution à terre alors
pourquoi l'église catholique il ya
effectivement des questions dont on
pourra débattre tout au long de la
soirée dans le dogme chrétien dans la
façon dont elle prépare aussi ses
prêtres sacerdoce mais je crois surtout
que aujourd'hui la vérité dans l'église
catholique s'est rendu coupable s'est
rendu coupable elle l'a établi elle même
et peut-être que on aura la désagréable
surprise de se rendre compte que
malheureusement peu d'institutions
sont épargnés par cette vague d'abus
sexuels de violences sexuelles sur en
particulier les mineurs qui je crois est
un phénomène dont on sous-estimé
l'importance partout dans la société et
d'ailleurs les chiffres que la
commission sauvé a permis d'établir à la
suite d'une enquête sociologique très
précises sont effarants on se rend
compte que c'est présent extrêmement
fortement dont beaucoup de familles en
france donc énormément d'endroits c'est
quelque chose je crois que c'est
véritablement l'un des maux du 21ème
siècle face auxquels on va devoir
regarder la réalité en face les enfants
abusés sont malheureusement extrêmement
nombreux et on les a certainement
sous-estimé jusqu'à maintenant et la
parole se libérant on va probablement
aller de découverte en découverte à
chaque fois avec effroi le célibat des
prêtres est soupçonné de favoriser la
pédocriminalité on l'a vu les réactions
à la publication du rapport sauvé sont
très souvent aller dans ce sens à croire
que si tous les hommes hétérosexuels de
ce pays si soudain il était privé de
femmes ils s'attaqueraient des petits
garçons
claude plein air puisque c'est le sujet
de votre livre qu'en pensez vous
j'en pense ce que ce qu'en dit le
rapport sauvé il dit qu'il n'ya pas de
lien de cause à effet entre le célibat
des prêtres et la pédocriminalité je le
pense aussi le problème c'est les
conditions d'accès au sacerdoce la
formation comment ce choix prend en
compte
un éventuel refoulement ou un évitement
de la sexualité ou un rapport pas clair
a sa propre histoire
ou des motivations inconscientes de
venir se mettre dans un milieu qui est
plus masculin où on va être en contact
d'enfants alors que finalement on n'est
pas on n'est pas où on est jamais au
clair avec sa sexualité mais on n'est
pas voilà on est dans un évitement de sa
propre sexualité d'un autre côté c'est
compliqué parce que quand on arrive dans
un séminaire c'était un long chemin la
maturation affective et sexuelle et on
sait pas d' avance à priori qui est dans
et et dans une attitude de possibles de
criminalité des habits d'un enfant ça
suit une longue histoire et moi je suis
je pense que la question la question
essentielle c'est celle de la formation
ne pas être dans l'antre soit des
séminaires d'être dans une de faire plus
parce aux sciences humaines à
l'accompagnement et à la maturité des
candidats au sacerdoce qui soit qu'ils
aient une expérience de vie et qu'ils
aient une maturité affective et c'est
pas toujours où forcément le cas anne
soupa
le rapport de la pièce a pointé
effectivement la question de
l'immaturité affective et moi je vois
bien moi qui suis mariée depuis
longtemps qui est une famille qui
travaille et je vois bien que à 20 25
ans même trente ans on est tous dans un
état d' immaturité affective et que la
vie la vie se charge de vous de vous
donner petit à petit cette maturité
affective qu'on a peut-être d'ailleurs
jamais mais sur laquelle son logement de
laquelle on progresse et je crains que
la vie des prêtres en séminaire loin du
travail oit d'une relation conjugale et
bien les conditions pour avancer dans la
maturité affective ne sont peut-être pas
toutes là et que c'est un facteur
facilitant des à vue mais je ne suis pas
assez compétente pour aller plus loin
peut-être que notre ami psychiatre
voudra dire quelque chose de plus sensé
que ce que je dis que moi alors wait
hallebardiers vous qui est là pour
traiter des pédophiles des pédocriminels
ça n'est pas la même chose peut
peut-être le rappeler pourquoi et est
donc un certain nombre de prêtres alors
d'abord oui la différence pour moi
médecins en fait c'est que et même si ça
choque il ya très peu de pédocriminels
dans de gens qui passent à l'acte sur
des enfants qui sont sexuellement
attirée par des enfants donc qui sont
pédophiles et donc qu'ils sont
pédophiles est là pour bourg pour les
médecins la pédophilie c'est d'abord
l'attirance sexuelle vert vers un enfant
est donc très important on peut être
pédophile ne jamais passer à l'acte on
peut être pédophile en étant un homme ou
une femme et
quand on regarde le cas des
pédocriminels c'est à dire ceux qui sont
passés à l'acte ça n'était pas là dans
la plupart des cas des pédophiles c'est
ça et donc est alors c'est vrai qu'on
parle souvent dit maturité affective je
vous avouerai que les psychiatres et des
psychologues parlent d'une maturité
affective aussi depuis des années
c'est un peu un concept vous j'allais
dire puisque je sais pas non plus si ça
si ça change avec les années mais je
suis pas sûr que les prêtres qui sont
cons qu'on agit sur des enfants ont tous
eu 25 ou 30 ans en fait et la question
de l'immaturité affective elle se résout
pas non plus dans le collage dans la
relation du mariage à l'autre en fait un
vol dans le collage à l'autre parfois
d'ailleurs c'est parce que il va y avoir
une séparation parce qu'il va y avoir
quand on est en couple qui va y avoir
des agressions sexuelles de la part des
affaires des pédocriminels donc
finalement je sais pas s'il me le même
là le lien à l'autre où le mariage est
une solution à une maturité affective et
et dans le cas de deux du célibat et
notamment du célibat des prêtres est ce
que ça peut vous paraître un facteur
encourageant alors j'espère surtout que
c'est pas que le célibat n'est pas un
facteur de risque de pédophilie ou de
pédocriminalité parce qu'il ya 50% de
célibataire à paris et que il ya dans
notre société de plus en plus de gens
qui sont célibataires ils sont
célibataires et sont pas forcément
chaste alors chasse ça veut pas ça veut
pas dire abstinent pour un pour un mieux
être non plus c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose après enfin même si ici hélas
aujourd'hui cccc signe dans un sens puis
dans l'autre les gens enfin la question
du célibat c'est je rejoins un petit peu
ce qui s'est dit tout à l'heure c'est
surtout la question de comment on vit
son célibat de comment vit sa sexualité
et puis tu peux pas peut-être mettre un
petit peu au même niveau ce qu'on a pu
entendre un petit peu ce qui est ce qui
a écrit adam lassiaz c'est finalement
parfois de mettre un petit peu au même
niveau d'avoir une relation sexuelle
avec quelqu'un et d'avoir des relations
sexuelles avec un enfant enfin puisque
c'est les deux à empêcher l'entrée
guillemets ça peut-être que c'est une
problématique pour autant
voilà je pense que ce que les choses le
célibat en lui-même seule ne justifie
rien le ça ne protège pas de la
pédophilie ça ne protège pas de la pas
la pédocriminalité est aujourd'hui la
majorité des personnes qui se rendent
auteurs d'actes pédophilique d'actes
pardon pédocriminels sont mariés enfin
ça se passe d'abord dans la famille ça
se passe d'abord sur ses propres enfants
sur ses neveux sur ses nièces et c est
donc le mariage n'est pas en lui-même
fallait vous fait d'être en couple
protège pas du tout de ça en fait paul
sujet mauvais procès qu'on a fait ici et
là où c'est l'ibal
mauvais procès pas nécessairement parce
que dans l'église toutes les questions
sont toujours bonnes à apposer et
surtout que une institution comme le
célibat des prêtres qui est souvent
assez mal comprise et assez âprement
discutés par les fidèles eux mêmes si
elles étaient sujettes à tabou ce serait
dramatique donc je pense que c'est
important chaque fois que l'occasion se
présente de pouvoir discuter de son bien
fondé maintenant moi un des
enseignements les plus les plus
surprenants et quelque part les plus
blessants aussi que je retire de ce
rapport de la case c'est que les laïcs
aussi ont été fautifs il ya un certain
nombre de laïcs des centaines de
milliers d'entre eux qui sont mises en
cause mise en cause pour des faits
d'abus qu'ils auraient commis
directement ou alors pour avoir aussi
couvert des faits d'abus lorsqu'il était
au courant alors ça veut dire deux
choses évidemment dans le rapport de la
case et dans l'est notamment les
conclusions qui en sont tirées il y a
d'une certaine manière le procès du
cléricalisme
c'est à dire qu'effectivement
probablement qu'il ya quelque chose à
convertir dans la relation que l'église
entretient avec ses prêtres peut-être
aussi la charge qu'elle met sur leurs
épaules peut-être que nous avons à être
un peu plus indulgent avec nos prêtres
que nous avons à redécouvrir leur
humanité alors évidemment le prêtre
participe d'une humanité toute
particulière puisque il est élu en un
sens pour une mission
sont sans aucune mesure par rapport à
celles des autres laïque mais en même
temps on peut pas tout demander aux
prêtres on peut certainement pas leur
demander d'être des surhommes maintenant
au delà du procès du cléricalisme
c'est quelque part le des questions qui
sont posées à l'église tout entière dans
son fonctionnement dans sa culture
peut-être là la facilité avec laquelle
elle peut être tenté par moment de
mettre la poussière sous le tapis en
pensant protéger l'institution alors
qu'en réalité elle ne fait généralement
que l'affaiblir puisque une vérité qu'on
enterre une vérité conteste une vérité
qui finit toujours par nous exploser à
la figure et qui de toute façon fait du
tort et fait du mal aux personnes voilà
moi ce que je vois sur la question du
célibat des prêtres en particulier c'est
que avant les abus sexuels il ya presque
toujours des abus spirituel c'est ce
qu'avait très bien montré dans un livre
remarquable sur le sujet dont disney ce
delassus ce qu'est le prix de la grande
chartreuse et qui avait été missionnée
pour justement réfléchir à ces questions
là en particulier au sein des ordres
monastiques et il a très bien montré que
les abus spirituel c'est à dire en fait
l'abus d'autorité qui est fait par un
prêtre par un moine ou par une moniale
en peu en situation d'autorité ou
parfois même par des laïcs qui sont les
fondateurs de courant qui leur confère
une autorité spirituelle très importante
et bien ces abus sont
sont le fait de personnes aux profils
ecclésiastique très différent on en
trouve des abus spirituel chez les
femmes comme chez les hommes alors
évidemment le passage à l'acte sexuel
est beaucoup plus commun chez les hommes
pour des raisons qui sont communes à la
crimes sexuels en général c'est à dire
que de toute façon les crimes sexuels
dans une société sont très généralement
si ce n'est quasiment toujours le fait
des hommes bons mais au-delà de cette
question vous voyez c'est la place de
l'autorité des religieux et des
religieuses des prêtres aussi qui est
questionnée
peut-être que l'église a
un peu de travail encore à faire sur ce
sujet là elle le fait déjà je crois dans
les séminaires on a par exemple dans le
figaro publié une très belle enquête qui
montre comment est-ce qu effectivement
on essaie peut-être de relâcher un petit
peu la pression sur le dos des
séminaristes en leur disant mais oui
vous est destiné à être des prêtres mais
vous ne serez pas des surhommes ne serez
pas des anges pour autant et vous devez
pas oublier votre part d'humanité à
laquelle vous ne renoncerai jamais en
fait voilà donc ce travail là il est
nécessaire pour autant je crois que si
on se focalise uniquement sur la
question du célibat des prêtres à mon
avis on manquera l'essentiel des
enseignements de ce rapport et on
restera dans des fausses polémiques qui
à mon avis n'iront pas jusqu'au bout de
ce que cela veut dire sur peut-être
l'origine des abus spirituel dans
l'église alors c'est pas seulement les
violences sexuelles qui sont commises en
majorité par les hommes c'est toutes les
violences c'est toute la délinquance se
sont tous les crimes qui sont commis en
anglais j'aurais grande majorité par les
hommes vous lirez agir que peithner
oui je suis je crois quand même qu'il ya
un problème de fond qui est là
le lien dans l'église catholique
entre ce célibat des prêtres le pouvoir
l'autorité la gouvernance le fait que
tout ça soit lié que le droit canon leur
donne à la fois la gouvernance
l'autorité le célibat tout ça tu en
voilà entre hommes en plus dans un
milieu masculin ne naît pas à clarifier
les choses et qu'un milieu ou l'altérité
j'aurais plus où la relation homme femme
j'aurais plus où la gouvernance serait
davantage partagée avec des
contre-pouvoirs dans un milieu moins
masculin je pense que ça débloquerait
déjà beaucoup de choses et que rien
n'empêche en soi bien ne l'empêchent
d'abord le célibat des prêtres ça a été
une longue histoire ça n'a en rien dogme
ça n'est en rien une fondée sur une
théologie c'est une pratique c'est une
discipline qui s'est mis en place sur
douze siècles on pourrait très bien
envisager d'ordonner des hommes mariés
aujourd'hui comme aux débuts de la
primitive églises les responsables des
communautés des bons pères de famille
rien n'empêche ça donc je crois qu'il y
aurait un coût à un chantier à rouvrir
sur ce lien entre sexualité et pouvoir
dans l'église catholique et sur le lien
aux femmes dans cet ancêtre là sans
cette gouvernance à une soupape fait
d'accord avec ce que wenger plattner
avec votre permission je voudrais
revenir sur le propos de paul suivi l
instant je pense que il y a quelque
chose dans la conception du sacrement de
l'ordre qui me paraît à revoir je crois
que le ministère
aura en grande crise parce qu'il a été
sacralisé c'est le seul sacrement dont
on dit dans le code de droit canon qu'il
ait de droit divin et hélas on ne peut
pas empêcher que c'est quelque chose qui
favorisent les abus quand vous êtes
investi d'une mission à un titre divin
et bien la personne qui est en face de
vous n'a pas la faculté de vous résistez
vous êtes avec des glissements
successifs vous êtes dieu bon donc là il
ya très certainement quelque chose à
revoir et c'est le code milles 8 du code
de droit canon milieu 8 du code de droit
canonique je pense qu'il ya vraiment un
travail profond à faire là-dessus le
ministère ordonné doit être revue je
vais pas dire à la baisse parce que pour
moi c'est un gain quand on gagne en
humanité
mais on doit le désacraliser parce que
c'est une charge trop lourde à porter
pour lui et pour son entourage voilà ça
ça me paraît vraiment important de
travailler là-dessus mais je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit d'actualité walter
hallebardiers le sentiment
d'hyperpuissance don king
dont elle parle toutes les deux je
rejoins ça c'est là que la question de
la toute-puissance ce qu'on appelle un
peu la toute puissance de d'être un peu
sans limites bien sûr que c'est
certainement un élément favorable à ça
d'ailleurs vous mettrez un peu de un peu
de de nuance c'est que je pense que
c'est vrai pour les hommes comme pour
les femmes on voit aussi et que ce soit
dans l'institution catholique comme
comme ailleurs aussi des femmes qui en
position de toute puissante fonds soient
retrouvés à être dans l'abus de l'autre
etc à la question y compris chez les
soeurs y compris chez les soeurs est
compris dans les institutions ayant
d'ailleurs je crois que sur le rapport
sauvé on parle d'environ 10% d'auteur
qui seraient des femmes dans ma clinique
à moi
je trouve je crois qu'on est un peu je
suis à peu près sûr les sur les mêmes
auraient sur les mêmes les mêmes
chiffres la question allait moins celle
du du génitales entre guillemets du sexe
attribué que la question de pouvoir et
les agressions sexuelles sont bien
souvent comme les abus sur l'autre
quelque chose de l'ordre du pouvoir en
fête et de la toute-puissance pas le
sujet
oui alors simplement j'aimerais répondre
deux petites choses alors sur la
question de savoir de quelle nature
exactement et le sacrement
du sacerdoce
je pense qu'on se trompe un petit peu
entre deux choses c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on soup a dit finalement d'étape
en étape le prêtre fini par se prendre
pour dieu elle décrit précisément le
comportement des prêtres abuseurs qu'il
s'agisse d'abus spirituel ou même des
abus plus grave encore puisque avec les
abus sexuels il ya un passage à l'acte
mais voyez c'est exactement la mécanique
qui s'est opérée dans l'esprit ça a été
assez bien décrit d'ailleurs dans pas
mal d'affaires qui ont pu être vraiment
mise en lumière là dessus dans l'esprit
de prêtres qui ont fini par justement
perdre la mesure de leur sacerdoce qui
n'est pas justement le fait de se
prendre pour dieu mais qui est le fait
d'être serviteur de dieu et bien sûr
servir dieu à travers le service de son
église voyez par exemple il ya une
affaire qui a fait je crois beaucoup de
mal à de nombreux fidèles catholiques
c'est qu'il commence à être établi sur
le comportement de jean vanier bon c'est
terrible parce que jean vanier en
fondant l'archa bien sûr réaliser une
oeuvre je crois à ces merveilleuses qui
continuent encore aujourd'hui de porter
beaucoup de fruits mais enfin on a vu
que jean vanier lorsque il a il a commis
tous les abus qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
reprochés l'a fait précisément en se
faisant presque passer pour du auprès de
ses victimes et il le faisait pas jean
régnier n'était pas prêtre il ne faisait
pas au nom de son sacerdoce mais
simplement parce que son charisme
l'éclat peut-être aussi de ces oeuvres
lui ont donné une assise une aura une
autorité dont un moment il n'a plus su
se départir et qui a fini par lui monter
à la tête voyait mais on dépasse ici là
la simple question du sacerdoce et
ensuite je vais redire à une soupe à une
chose qu'elle a certainement entendu
beaucoup de fois mais je crois que froch
c'est un argument qui mérite d'être
entendu et il ya toujours une forme de
gêne quand on va directement sur la
question du célibat des prêtres comme
explication à
la forte proportion des abus sexuels
dans l'église vous voyez c'est de
prendre la question à l'envers et se
demander mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
en fait c'est à dire que
il avait une épouse tous ces prêtres et
ce qu'ils auraient été moins enclins à
abuser des enfants voyez qu'est ce que
ça signifie de la place et de la valeur
qu'on accorde à la sexualité est ce que
c'est un défouloir qui est censé vide et
l'homme de ses mauvais penchants août
ses désirs criminelle bon je suis pas
certain que ce soit une vision de la
sexualité qu'on ait envie de défendre en
fait c'est une vraie question au delà
parce qu'on a parlé delà du discours
plus générale de l'église sur la sur la
sexualité on n'est pas simplement la
sexualité chez les prêtres c'est une
vraie question c'est à dire qu'est-ce
qui fait ou font l'originalité de
l'enseignement d'église sur
l'inscription de la sexualité dans
l'amour humain
l'église est une des institutions au
monde capable discours le plus exigeant
non pas seulement sur la sexualité mais
sur l'amour en général et en dix ans de
façon très nette que dans le plan de
dieu la sexualité s'inscrit comme étant
au service de l'amour qu'elle peut pas
être désiré seulement pour elle même et
qu'elle est désiré justement en vue de
faire grandir l'amour entre deux êtres
on
pourra pas refaire si vous voulez tout
la théologie chrétienne sur la question
de l'amour humain et l'amour chaste
entre un homme et une femme mais vous
voyez que en rentrant dans ces
considérations
au fond on donne à la sexualité une
place bien plus importante que d'être
simplement un défouloir où un endroit où
on peut et penchez des désirs et qui
serait presque nécessaire pour éviter de
tomber dans des dérives et c'est parfois
un peu le risque de ce débat lorsque
l'on se focalise un peu trop sur la
question du célibat des prêtres je crois
je vous propose de faire une pause et on
reprend ce débat juste après
[Musique]
président à vie en perdre la vie pascal
affi n'guessan quelles sont les raisons
qui poussent les chefs d'état à se
maintenir au pouvoir en afrique ce n'est
pas seulement parce que ses chefs on
essaie de tendance cette volonté de
rester mais c'est parce que en face il
n'y a pas de honte le pouvoir
suffisamment fort et le punit contre le
pouvoir c'est pourquoi l'organisation
d'élections transparentes reste toujours
un défi sur le continent africain est
encore dans ou de pays africains une
forte proportion de la population qui a
attaché à la question technique donc qui
ne sont pas encore acquises à la
démocratie est ce que vous serez
candidat en 2025 et est ce que si vous
deviez l'emporter vous promettez
justement de ne jamais briguer un
troisième mandat si vous allez me
automates mbi
50 cc c'est le temps qu'il nous faudra
donc un seul mandat on retient cette
promesse à pascal affi n'guessan
[Musique]
il ya eu celle et panama peppers les
paradise peppers place aujourd'hui aux
pandora peppers la plupart de ces de ces
opérations sont en fait parfaitement
légale y a rien de nouveau sous le
soleil on révèle effectivement un
système dans lequel il a probablement
enfin incontestablement de plus en plus
de fuite devant l'impôt de plus en plus
de correction et de plus en plus de
difficulté des gouvernements avoir un
brin de contrôle sur ces masses d'argent
et qui circulent on pourrait simplement
arrêté au-delà ware ou dans d'autres
états comme ça de permettre ces
fonctionnements et c'est blanchiment ce
que vous pensez sérieusement que demain
le dakota du sud va arrêter ses
pratiques et qu'on va lui faire arrêter
ces pratiques non pas du tout
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec walter
hallebardiers qui est psychiatre avec
anne soupa qui était au low gêne et qui
publie pour l'amour de dieu chez albin
michel avec claude plattner qui est
également théologienne et qui elle
publie choisir le célibat avec un point
d'interrogation aux éditions du cerf et
avec paul sujet qui est journaliste au
figaro
si ça n'est pas le célibat des prêtres
est-ce que c'est laid l'église qui
attirerait les pédophiles ou en tout cas
ceux capables ou est ce qu'elle est on
favoriserait le passage à l'acte est ce
qu elle
parle la loi du silence qui est le
secret de la confession en plus c'est ce
qu'elle couvrirait les crimes qui ont pu
être commis et elle est ce qu'elle
permettrait aux pédocriminels de sévir
plus longtemps voilà certains nombres de
d'explication qui ont été données alors
je me tourne vers vous alter
hallebardiers puisque vous vous traitez
des pédophiles et des pédocriminels
notamment des prêtres qu'est ce qu'il ya
de vrai éventuellement dans tout cela
devrait c'est que comme toute
institution comme l'est la famille comme
sont d'autres écoles comme le font
d'autres instances comme des
associations et cetera
l'église pendant des années alors je
pense d'abord n'a pas pris la mesure de
ce qui était qu'une agressions sexuelles
sur enfants et pendant des années on a
finalement beaucoup banalisée ça alors
il ya eu plusieurs mouvements de
libération la parole sur ses talents en
amérique du nord à c'est plutôt là où
l'église résister où elle a été obligée
de se confronter à ses responsabilités
oui mais fois même en france un la
question de la reconnaissance des
violences sexuels sur les mineurs
extrait dans l'église ou ailleurs elle a
eu plusieurs phases il ya eu les années
80 et puis on a reçu un peu ce phénomène
pour en désigner comme coupable des
pédophiles extrafamilial le grand
méchant loup qui pourrait nous permettre
de penser qu'il n'y avait rien à voir
dans nos institutions ou dans ce qu'on
connaissait enfin c'était pas nous qui
étions responsables de ça et puis à
nouveau là il ya quelque chose qui se
parlent en notre société autour de de
ces faits mais bien sûr que ces
institutions d'abord ne mesurait pas la
gravité de ces choses là est très claire
et puis et puis qu'elle couvrait parfois
par
volonté de pas de cachet finalement de
ne pas éviter le scandale et puis dans
une forme de banalisation et en ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure finalement la
position de toute puissance et 2 et 2
finalement de d'exemplarité du prêtre
leur a été encore écornée à cause de ça
et finalement on a couvert beaucoup de
choses alors on l'a couvert là mais
comme dans beaucoup d'institutions je
crois qu'il faut aussi se dire
qu'aujourd'hui la famille elle va être
aussi mise à l'épreuve et un autre type
d'institution on va dire dans notre
société elle va être mise à l'épreuve
par une par la commission sur l'inceste
qui est en train de se mettre en place
en france aussi et que on va aussi
certainement tomber de haut et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est près de 20% des
jeunes et des femmes qui ont été quand
% des jeunes femmes louis qui ont été
agressées sexuellement dans leur vie et
dans l'eure et en particulier avant 18
ans et sa 6 à 7% des enfants des garçons
oui et on est on est sur des chiffres
qui sont explosifs alors après qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait pas la question c'est
plutôt que de désigner un coupable que
ce soit le prêtre ou que ce soit le le
pédophile extrafamilial je parle de
d'emile louis ou de ce qui a pu bien me
tromper mais trouva
ce qu'a pu faire beaucoup de papier dans
les années 90 la question elle est comme
des gens responsables on va voir si
l'église est là dedans de commencer à se
poser les vraies questions sur notre
rapport à l'autre notre rapport à la
sexualité dans cette société sur la
capacité qu'on a aussi d'accueillir la
parole d'être vigilant
des personnes qui sont en difficultés
dans les relations avec les enfants
alors nous on navire l'ait les
pédophiles juste whissell qui ne trompe
pas passer à l'acte et que ceux qui sont
pédophiles ou ceux qui se voient se
perdre dans une relation avec un enfant
parce que au fond il n'y a pas de
sentiment de toute puissance s'il ya un
tiers qui à côté qui dit attention est
ce que tu qu'est ce que tu fais dans
cette relation là quelqu'un qui ait ou
pas pédophile d'ailleurs c'est pas la
question est elle qui peut être un
psychiatre d'ailleurs bien sûr mais
d'ailleurs laitière vous savez que dans
tout les abus de pouvoir et la
psychiatrie nom n'a jamais été
complètement au dénué dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques ya des choses qui se
passent qui sont aux terribles et bien
sûr que la question c'est de la même
saison ce qui est des tiers qui était un
regard extérieur dans ces institutions
que ce soit la prison que ce soit la
psychiatrie que ce soit à l'hôpital
d'une façon générale que ce soit la
famille qui est des tiers qui permette
de sortir de position ou de
positionnement et de rivalités de toute
puissance et
le fait que des gens qui auraient des
fantasmes sur des enfants seraient
attirés
par l'église ça vous paraît possible moi
j'ai jamais rencontré de prêtres qui
rentrait dans cette voie là pendant dix
ans je suis pédophiles chouette une
tapée des gains j'ai jamais vu ça et je
crois que c'est quand même un grand
résumé alors après qu effectivement des
gens choisissent cette voie parce qu'il
ya une forme de rassurer assurance
d'être entre hommes d'être dense quelque
chose d'à sexualisé entre guillemets et
cetera et cetera c'est possible et c'est
évident qu'il peut y avoir des parcours
comme ça la réalité c'est que pour
beaucoup finalement
et là comité de la commission sauvé elle
le dit hein seulement 10% serait
vraiment atteindre paraphilie de puits
d'eau de vivres et de pédophilie la
majorité s'est finalement leur position
et leur posture et la position qu'ils
prennent de toute puissance et de 200
filtré de sang et sans limite à l'autre
baky fini par les faire dévier peu le
sujet sur
sur le secret de la confession vous avez
réagi vous avez créé un article là
dessus on s'est beaucoup pour flammes et
parce que un cardinal avait dit que le
le secret de la confession était au
dessus des lois de la république
il faut dire qu'il faut qu'ils aient
beaucoup d'ignorance et de la part de
cet évêque et de la part des
journalistes au tour puisque
effectivement le secret de la confession
il n'est pas au dessus il fait partie
des douanes la république avec quelques
limites mais comme voilà il ya dans les
lois de la république à 2,62 secret
professionnel et le secret de la
confession
en fait partie
oui alors vous faites beaucoup d'honneur
à monseigneur moulins beaufort en le
créant cardinal seul le pape à cette
prérogative pour l'instant mais
effectivement le porte parole de la
conférence des évêques de france s'est
retrouvée dans une émission
de radio où le journaliste a tenu à tout
prix à lui faire dire que le secret de
la confession place et l'église au
dessus des lois et puis il a essayé de
protester un peu de sortir la question
qui était un peu piégeuse et puis en fin
de compte il a fini par avoir cette
expression extrêmement maladroite
l'église n'est certainement pas au
dessus des lois en tous les cas les les
les fidèles qui la composent sont soumis
aux lois de la république comme
n'importe quel autre citoyen n'importe
quel autre justiciable et sur cette
question en particulier du secret de la
confession on a la chance et ça il faut
le reconnaître c'est ça tient aussi à la
générosité avec laquelle le régime
républicain reconnaît la liberté de
conscience et la liberté de religion on
a la chance de vivre effectivement dans
un pays où le droit canon sur cette
question là est tout à fait en
conformité avec le droit civil
ce qui a été rappelé par la suite c'est
à dire que le secret de la confession
est reconnu par là par le droit français
comme étant un secret professionnel
comparable à celui des avocats ou celui
des médecins
il ya une exception qui veut que
effectivement les prêtres sont détachés
de ce secret lorsqu'ils ont connaissance
de faits qui notamment impliquent des
abus sur des mineurs alors ce qui veut
dire qu'ils ne sont pas tenus par la loi
de dénoncer les faits mais qu'ils en ont
la possibilité sans être poursuivis
pénalement parce que en dehors de ces
quelques exceptions un prêtre qui
travaillait en secret qui lui a été
confiée en tant que prêtre ne peut être
poursuivi par là par la loi parce que
quand on est détenteur d'un secret
professionnel on n'a pas le droit de le
divulguer sous quelques motifs que ce
soit alors sur cette question là je vous
ai entendu tout à leur dire que l'église
cultivait enfin qu'elle avait en son
sein une culture du secret
propos avec lequel je suis
malheureusement parfaitement d'accord
avec vous et ensuite vous l'avez liées
au secret de la confession et c'est là
que je suis moins d'accord je m'explique
il ya deux choses très différentes
la casa établi avec une acuité qui est
indiscutable l'existence d'une culture
de la dissimulation au sein de l'église
c'est à dire que lorsque des
ecclésiastiques et a fortiori notamment
des responsables et des évêques ont
connaissance de certains faits qui
peuvent mettre un petit peu en cause la
réputation de leur institution ils sont
parfois hésitants voire ils vont
carrément refusé de transmettre ses
informations de les éclairer ou alors
s'ils demandent une enquête interne par
exemple en confiant au vicaire général
du diocèse le soin d'en apprendre plus
sur les prêtres au sujet desquels
circulent des rumeurs et bien il ne
transmet pas toujours ces informations à
la justice c'est quelque chose qui est
terrible qui est je crois un motif de
honte pour non seulement tous les to les
ecclésiastiques qui ont dissimulé mais à
travers eux pour toute l'institution et
il est temps vraiment d'encourager
l'église à être complètement
transparente sans aucune complaisance
sur tous ces faits là voilà ça c'est dit
maintenant la question du secret de la
confession pour moi être à part parce
qu'elle concerne en fait la relation
d'intimité qui existe entre le prêtre et
le croyant et de ce point de vue là le
prêtre et des deux côtés c'est à dire
qu'il parle à la fois des victimes à des
coupables mais j'irai plus loin c'est à
dire que l'église ne considère pas que
la séparation entre le bien et le mal
c'est une frontière extérieure à chaque
personne mais qu'elle nous traverse tout
entier c'est à dire que le le drame de
l'existence humaine
éclairé par le message de l'évangile
c'est de se reconnaître à la fois comme
victime et comme coupables et donc en se
confessant on peut être tour à tour
amené à reconnaître les fautes qu'on a
commises en même temps parfois confié
dans la relation de confiance qu'on a
avec le prêtre certains abus certaines
fautes dont on aurait pu nous mettre
victimes et je crois qu'il ya une
tribune merveilleuse qui a été publié
n'est quelques jours dans la croix qui
montre très bien comment est ce que la
parole de certaines victimes a pu se
libérer petit à petit justement au
contact de prêtres acquis les personnes
ont fait confiance et si peut-être y
avait pas eu ce lien privilégié dans
l'intimité alors c'est pas toujours la
confession au sens du sacrement mais en
tous les cas c'est la relation le
dialogue il s'installe entre le prêtre
et le fidèle et bien sans cette relation
de confiance peut-être que certains
auraient n'aurait pas parlé ou reparler
plus difficilement voyez donc je crois
que c'est important de continuer à 100
que tu as he is et cette intimité qui
existe qui passe par un secret qui en
fait en tours justement d'une vraie
confiance la parole du fidèle
ce qui ne veut pas dire que l'église n'a
pas à côté le devoir de mettre en
lumière chaque fois qu'elle en a
connaissance des faits d'abus des faits
de violences sexuelles mais même de viol
commis en son sein voyelles et pour moi
ce sont deux choses différentes anne
soupa
je voudrais revenir sur dans la question
de la décision qui n'est pas prise parce
qu'on est que dans l'antre soirée bon je
crois pièce est quand même un lieu de
masculinité très grand l'église
catholique au niveau des décisionnaires
et là vous avez un facteur qui favorise
la dissimulation et sans doute les
violences elle même comme l'a dit
nathalie bajos lors de la conférence de
presse de la sias non
plus la domination masculine est forte
plus les violences sexuelles sont fortes
at elle dit donc un lieu tel que le
clergé un lieu exclusivement masculin
est un lieu qui ne favorise pas
justement l'aide d'un tiers comme le
rappelait monsieur tout de suite qui a
lié un tiers qui dit mais attention qu
est ce que tu es en train de faire bon
là il n'y a pas ça et ça favorise
probablement là le passage
en ce que lui production de femmes dans
l'église est une décision urgente à
prendre
quand tu meurs
ça m'a fait un peu sourire ce débat ce
débat sur la confession parce que on en
parle on en parle presque plus dans
l'église catholique il ya de moins en
moins de 4 litres qui se confesse et
subitement ça devient un sujet de
société je trouve que ça manque pas
d'humour bon mais ceci dit le sujet est
grave donc je perds mada la parenthèse
je crois avoir entendu que monseigneur
de moulins beaufort vous les avez
reconnu qu' il fallait réfléchir à cette
question dans l'église catholique lors
après son entretien avec le ministre de
l'intérieur et qui la visent à les faire
là la conférence épiscopale de france
allait faire des propositions
donc c'est pas un sujet aussi simple que
ça en a l'air et il faut effectivement
continuer à travailler moi je crois
aussi que il me semble que rien n'oblige
un prêtre lors du sacrement de la
confession a
accordé son absolution quand il se
trouve face à un crime un crime déjà
ordinaire mais un crime encore plus par
rapport à un enfant il n'est pas du tout
obligé de me peuvent refuser
l'absolution est fortement encouragé
cette personne à aller se dénoncer à la
justice si dis-je ajoute aussitôt que
c'est un certain c'est une situation qui
se retrouve très peu on voit rarement un
pédophile un train en confession et on
voit rarement fin je crois que c'est ça
m'a tout l'air un peu mois d'un certain
faux problème 1 et que bon ça prend une
proportion important que je le comprends
en tout cas moi j'ai une conviction
c'est que effectivement aucun chrétien
n'est au dessus des lois de la
république mais claude tonnerre oublions
un moment la confession en tant que tel
à partir du moment on a cru voir à tort
ou à raison
l'épiscopat
pas toujours pas à chaque fois mais il
est arrivé il serait arrivé que
l'épiscopat couvre c'est à dire qu'à un
moment tel prêtre soupçonné soit laissé
à son poste en contact des enfants ce
qu'on appelle mettre la poussière sous
le tapis ça ce serait typique de
l'église catholique alors pour les
raisons peut-être qui a évoqué anne
soupa ou pas mais ça est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vrai
est-ce que c'est typique des l'église
catholique j'en sais rien ce qui est sûr
le déni il est incontestable des need
existe quatre lits qu'il est
incontestable est debout là bas voulu
dissimuler pour protéger l'institution
c'est indéniable même les épais qui le
reconnaissent pas tous mais la grande
majorité des évêques le reconnaissent un
succès ça me parait samba essentiel
après que toute institution cherchent à
se protéger est-ce que c'est propre à
l'église catholique est là en moins le
courage d'essayer de faire le ménage et
de voir la vérité en face
douloureusement difficilement après
longtemps d'erreurs mais elle le fait et
je crois que toute institution devrait
s'interroger son âme et la honte elle se
protège par rapport à tout ça et met la
poussière sous le tapis ça n'est pas
réservé 10 catholique parce que y'a faso
et façon de se protéger la mafia pour se
protéger elle élimine celui qui la gêne
y compris quand il fait partie de la
mafia là dans le cas de l'église
catholique c'est ce qu'on lui reproche
c'est d'avoir laissé à leur poste des
gens qui étaient des menaces
c'est arrivé ça et est ce que vous avez
été au contact de ceux de ceux là où
elle perd hallebardiers non moi j'ai
plutôt été au contact parce que
ça fait quand même quelques années qui
est une vraie réflexion dans l'église
sur ces situations là il ya certainement
encore des positions de dénis etc mais
il ya aussi une vraie prise en charge et
une brune près prise en compte de ces
situations là est la vraie question
c'est au fond qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
ces gens dans cette institution qui sont
passés à l'acte parce qu'au fond est ce
qu'il faut pour autant les renvoyer
alors le pas les laisser au contact
d'enfants c'est bien sûr probablement sa
part est pénible ça paraît minimum mais
on a aussi reproché à un moment de l'est
qui finissaient leur vie dans des
institutions à ses protégés du monde
extra oui enfin la protection protégés
du monde c'est aussi un monde qui est
protégé la vraie question c'est qu'est
ce que l'église doit finalement
lâché ces gens là mais c'est au fond la
même question qui a dans notre société
c'est à dire est ce que les gens qui un
jour commettre des actes sur les enfants
il faut finalement juste et mettre en
prison et faire semblant qu'il n'existe
plus non il existe encore et qu'est ce
qu'on doit mettre en place pour et les
protégés de leur vulnérabilité à passer
à l'acte et surtout et aussi protéger la
société de leurs actions en fait et
finalement ça s'est quand même une vraie
question qui est rarement posée
d'ailleurs qu'on qu'on trouve pas
beaucoup traité dans la ciat zinsel au
fond finalement qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces
gens là mais vous le savez bien
naturellement les gens vont répondre il
faut plus qu'il sorte bah oui vous le
diront c'est la perpétuité il faut plus
qu'il faut envoyer mais ça marche pas
comme ça la vraie vie en fait et puis
alors hissés dans les années 90 on a
fait un truc très bien c'est pour se
dire il faut que les psychiatres
finalement les sauts avec dans ce cas
est ce qu a créé finalement une un
dispositif qui n'existait pas dans la
loi auparavant c'est la question des de
l'injonction de soins et donc d'un coup
il fallait que disparaisse la pédophilie
de dans les gens oui alors c'est une
chose mais d'abord c'est pas toujours
une maladie c'est parfois juste enfin
juste ça c'est parfois comme par l'état
leur de l'immaturité affective des
choses un peu compliquées prise en
charge les nécessaire mais elle n'est
pas que sanitaire elle aussi sociale
elle est aussi judiciaire elle est aussi
finalement de tout l'environnement de la
société qui doit se poser de vraies
questions de savoir comment on fait avec
ces gens là alors là par définition
banon on n'y a pas de peine de mort en
france il ya pas de perpétuité réelle
pour quelqu'un qui commettraient des
attouchements sexuels sur un enfant
et d'un coup bah oui il faut qu'on
réfléchisse vraiment à ce qui se passe
derrière et pour l'église finalement
c'est un peu la même question c'est ça
aussi c'est au béret dans l'histoire
sert que on veut on veut dénoncer on
veut mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces gens
et ça c'est la question durant semble
qui est là dedans aussi quand même pas
le sujet
oui je me permet de rebondir sur une
expression qu'on peut à un moment walter
alva dit peut-être elle est un peu
maladroite c'est à dire que je crois pas
que l'église
par sa nature même ne puisse lâcher qui
que ce soit l'église de l'ach personnes
voyez elle peut renvoyer d'été avec les
astique un de ces prêtres pour des
raisons graves d'ailleurs il ya une
réforme du droit canon qui va rentrer en
vigueur dans quelques semaines quelques
mois et qui précise notamment qui
caractérise beaucoup plus précise et mon
regard du droit interne de l'église la
question des abus sexuels et c'est une
excellente chose mais on peut renvoyer
un prêtre on peut dénoncer lorsqu'un
évêque a connaissance des agissements
d'un prêtre de son diocèse il est bien
sûr
tenu de dénoncer cela auprès des
autorités civiles compétentes
mais pour autant l'église ne lâche pas
ses enfants voyez l'église entretien
avec la justice une relation privilégiée
notamment à travers par exemple la
pastorale des prisonniers l'église est
souvent celle qui apporte de l'espérance
à ceux qui n'en n'ont plus et parfois
les criminels sont les premiers d'entre
eux voyaient dire qu' il n'y aurait pas
dans le fait de traduire de faire
traduire en justice et de donner une
profonde transparence sur les actes
commis par ces par ses prêtres il y
aurait pas là une forme de lâcheté de
l'église à l'égard de ses brebis
galeuses au contraire plus que jamais
c'est dans la vérité que l'église peut
continuer d'accompagner ces personnes
qui restent malgré tout les enfants
chéris du bon dieu ça c'est quelque part
le grand mystère de 2 que qu'enseigne
l'église c'est que le bon dieu aime à la
fois le pire comme le meilleur des
hommes le pire bourreau comme la plus
innocente des victimes voyez mais ce
serait dangereux de faire croire que si
l'église opère ce nécessaire travail de
vérité pour autant elle lâcherait ses
prêtres non c'est pas du tout le sujet
simplement effectivement le fait d'être
prêtres catholiques n'est besoin d'un
exemple bien sûr de respect d'aucune loi
et en particulier
sur ces sujets là il faut être
extrêmement clair
après tremblay ce doublement l'humanité
en lui quand il commet des actes
terribles comme des agissements
pédophiles parce que bien sûr il fait du
mal à une victime ça tous les pédophiles
le fond mais en plus en tant qu en sa
qualité de prêtre il écorne quelque
pages l'image que que se font les gens
du corps du christ voyait donc en plus
de ça il le bleis l'église elle-même a
traversé à travers ces crimes joseph
dérange c'est à dire aux
affaires on peut juger parce qu'il ya
claude plein air qui qui boudent de
vouloir intervenir un club fait mal et
elle a l'air pas du tout d'accord avec
vous
non mais autant je suis d'accord sur le
sur le soin de c2c prêtre c'est une
vraie question c'est une vraie question
on peut pas les lâcher comme ça et la
solution n'est pas facile mais je suis
vous trouve quand même très content très
comment dire je cherche un terme qui
soit pas trop négatif je vous trouve
très complaisant avec cette église moi
je suis témoin à longueur de temps un de
personnes qui se sentent lâchés par
l'église je pense en particulier à des
homosexuels ou à des couples homosexuels
ou à des divorcés remariés qui sont
extrêmement dans la souffrance je ne
dirais pas aussi vite que vous que
l'église ne lâche pas ses enfants chéris
sanaa certains noms c'est écouter six à
avoir ce à avoir par rapport je pense à
au rapport de difficile de l'église à la
sexualité entre autres et c'est dans ce
domaine que justement beaucoup beaucoup
je ne dis pas la majorité mais un
certain nombre de personnes se sentent
juger ou exclus ou pas accueillis par
leur mode de vie et leurs comportements
en couple ou d'en haut d'en haut dans
leur roue dans l'eure l'eure l'eure la
manière dont ils vivent leur sexualité
et donc on peut pas gommer ça d'un
revers de main en disant que l'église
est accueillante et qu'il n'y a pas de
problème circulez ya rien à voir
elle ne suis pas
sous pas pardon
non non l'église et je pense comme
claude que l'église n'est pas toujours
accueilli donc mais effectivement comme
le dit paul est là elle a tout de même
cette qualité énorme de savoir que nous
sommes tous ambivalent tout ce fauteur
du mal comme du bien et que nous
pourtant ça en nous de manière quasiment
un débit
je suis bien gré de 2 cm mais je pense
que plus largement on peut tout de même
constater que l'église n'a pas été très
vigilante dans la dans le suivi de la
manière dont elle devait laisser au
contact de jeunes s'est pressée ses
prêtres et contact des enfants moi j'ai
le cadre des amis suisses me disent
je leur dis mais que faites vous quand
vous avez un prêtre auteur d'abus et
elles me disent mais on l'envoie en
france très simplement
et quand je lis des rapports sur des cas
d'abus en france je vois que on les
envoie au maroc bon donc c'est quand
même assez comique cette façon de
renvoyer la patate chaude aux voisins si
je peux parler aussi crûment qui prouve
que on n'a toujours pas la bonne méthode
dont on ne sait pas comment faire et
très probablement que le soin sel c'est
la meilleure méthode mais le soin dans
un environnement humain qui reste
le creux est
inévitable la confrontation avec la
victime mais je pense aux aux
expériences de pardon partagé qu'il y a
eu ro rwanda et peut-être qu'il ya
quelque chose à un enseignement à tirer
de ces expériences ou victimes et
prédateurs finisse peut-être que c'est
irénique mais peut-être il faut aussi
réfléchir finissent par trouver le moyen
de se reparler de faire le bilan de ce
qui a été abîmée et de voir sur quel
avenir on peut tabler ça peut faire
partie de la solution
dernier mot walter hallebardiers alors
sur ça je partage complètement c'est ce
que dans la société on va dire civile
habituel on on appelle aujourd'hui la
justice restaurative qui en plein essor
de finalement de pouvoir rpt confronté
bah oui parfois victimes auteur et puis
surtout de restaurer et de restaurer la
justice à la place où il doit être c'est
à dire pas seulement la cad la
condamnation et la mise au pilori mais
aussi la réincorporation de la personne
dans le corps social et je pense que
finalement c'est un petit peu la même
chose que ceux dont on parle par rapport
aux prêtres qui ont commis des choses
d'été ça dans l'église c'est finalement
que comment on les traite et comment les
ré on les ré accueille dans cette
communauté et ça je pense qu'il ya quand
même quelque chose encore à définir et à
écrire mais aujourd'hui avec toutes les
affaires c'est le monstre le
pédocriminels et même le pédophile c'est
devenu le monstre quand bien même il n'a
rien fait il mais il lui a suffit d'y
penser pour devenir un monstre il est
confortable que ce soit un monstre ça
permet de montrer que c'est pas nous
c'est l'autre en fait c'est cette fois
la fonction à mon avis de bouc émissaire
de alors je suis pas en train de dire
que ce sont des pauvres personnes les
pédocriminels mais en tout cas c'est
bien pratique de dénoncer qui le
prêterait et c'est qui qui me louise que
c'est à l'heure plutôt que de se poser
la question de ce qu'on a comme action
auprès ce que ce qu'on a comme attitude
et quelles sont nos actions par envers
les enfants qu'on a sous sa garde qu'on
a dans sa famille et parfois ça aussi
c'est une vraie question je vous
remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]